le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais les
sapeurs-pompiers sont indispensables au
sein de notre vie collective il assure
assistance aux victimes lutte contre les
incendies et interviennent pour les
accidents de toute nature de manière
générale ils sont au coeur de la
sécurité civile et de la gestion des
crises ils s'inscrivent dans la vie
quotidienne des réunionnais cette
implication totale qui permet l'égalité
de nos territoires doit être saluée et
valorisé à quel âge peut-on commencer
quelles sont les conditions pour être un
sapeur pompier volontaire
on en parle tout de suite d'un lien
social
les sapeurs pompiers volontaires sont au
coeur du dispositif des secours ils
consacrent leur temps libre à la
préservation de l'île de ses biens et de
sa population à sauver des vies
maillon essentiel de la solidarité
locale et nationale ils doivent avoir
une condition physique compatible avec
une activité opérationnelle
le conseil général investit grandement
dans les moyens alloués aux tice caserne
véhicules mais aussi dans la formation
des femmes et des hommes
de jeunes sapeurs pompiers volontaires
ont suivi de manière assidue quatre
années de formation est passé avec
succès les épreuves du brevet national
marion 17 ans issus de cette formation a
intégré la caserne de la possession
jusqu'à sa majorité elle sera encadrée
par des tuteurs pour chacune de ses
gardes il évalue ses capacités et lui
donne des missions en conséquence
travailler en équipe et venir au secours
des personnes vulnérables ou en danger
sans sa motivation première
on parie les pompiers professionnels
donc c'est un milieu que je connais que
je connais bien j'ai presque grandi
dedans va dire je me suis engagé
en tant que jeune sapeur-pompier
à l'âge de 12 ans maintenant c'est 13 14
ans donc j'ai commencé par passer le
concours puis j'ai suivi quatre ans de
formation on a des épreuves physiques et
théorique en est formé comme des
pompiers professionnels ou
on fait du secours à personnes comme de
l' incendie au bout de ces quatre ans on
passe le brevet
ou les tests sont plus difficiles à
l'obtention du projet
on est appelé à venir chercher notre
paquetage donc on a eu la remise des
diplômes avec nassimah dindar et nos
officiers ça se passe bien pour
l'instant ça fait que deux semaines que
je suis rentré en caserne
j'ai pu intervenir une fois pour un
malaise puis pour la garde
présidentielle pour la venue du
président françois hollande on n'est pas
habitués à voir une iframe victimes à
faire un vrai bon gars d'âge on a contre
tous les jours en compte j'étais encadré
justement par mon tuteur
j'en ai trois donc je travaille avec eux
s'ils sont absents je ne peux pas
travailler c'est eux qui justement sont
là pour me tombait guider jusqu'à mes 18
ans je serai accompagné à chaque
intervention
tous les matins on à la prise de garde
on vérifie les véhicules
puis on fait notre sport et après j'ai
chaque jour à un programme donc ça
dépend des jours si on a des doutes on
sait qu'on parle avec nos équipiers afin
d'être sûr de ce qu'on va faire on m'a
préparé à tout à toute intervention
parce qu'elles sont toutes différentes
différentes l'une des autres et des
personnes c'est quelque chose
d'important si on les aide pas et que
nous un jour on a un problème
enfin nous aussi on aimerait être aidés
après plus tard j'ai une bonne formation
j'étais vraiment bien encadré
aujourd'hui je suis prête à aller à
intervenir sur toute intervention
on a le tout sous le même langage donc
je parle comme les autres pompiers même
s'ils ont plus d'expérience que moi je
comprends ce qu'ils ne disent ben pour
l'instant j'ai 17 ans je suis encore
mineurs donc j'ai
des tuteurs
j'interviens avec eux et après
j'envisage même d'être pompier
professionnel
peut-être que ce sera difficile mais
avec de la volonté on finit par paris
sia la réunion est fier de ses jeunes
recrues de plus en plus nombreux à
vouloir rejoindre le dise le conseil
général permet à ces jeunes d'exprimer
leurs potentialités de croire en leurs
talents et leur réussite
la réunion peut être rassuré de pouvoir
compter sur toute cette jeunesse prête à
donner de son temps de loisir à la
population pour que chaque difficulté de
la vie ne soit qu'un mauvais passage ces
jeunes filles et garçons représentent
l'espoir et l'avenir de notre île
encourageons les et soyons très fiers de
tous ces jeunes réunionnais prêt et
disponible à exercer ce beau métier qui
est sapeur-pompier volontaire
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais